e
e e
okay good morning everybody we're going
to get started on the uh subcommittee
for solid waste um we're a little bit
behind time we're supposed to start at
9: but it's 9:15 now and um we've got a
lot to cover in 15
minutes um so to start
um um representative germana has just um
passed out some amendments to us that we
can look at I know there were some
emails that were sent recently from
representative Penza and commissioner
whims we can discuss briefly um and then
also um chairwoman Ain has some
questions she's is not able to attend
right now but she might be here any
moment but I've um I've got some
questions of hers written down that I'll
ask um but before we get to that um
let's start off with um representative
Penza um if you have anything to say
about your work and what you've got
going on that'd be
great uh thank you Mr chair and
um everything has um been put into place
all of the changes that I had sent out
from the draft are all are all in so um
there were a couple of I'm going to go
through them they're better on my
computer than they are on the dra on the
draft real quick while you're looking
that up when you say the draft do you
mean the um the um copy that you handed
out uh a week or so ago that has a kind
of different type face it doesn't look
quite like OS but is drafted like OSS is
that what you're referring to the one
with the lines struct yeah yeah yeah
that has all been applied here in
this this is an unapproved draft you're
happy that everything that was in that
draft did make it into this amendment
correct everything I spent was here
yesterday looking line by line to make
sure that it was all done uh correctly
as well okay I'll just blast with the
real quick questions while you're
looking that up the Ford Act is that in
or
out the what act the Ford Act is that in
out uh that is still in I believe um you
had mentioned previously you wanted to
get rid of that um do you have a reason
why you kept it in or it was kept
in
um yeah lines it's it's on lines page
three lines 15 16 17 I just kept it in
because it wasn't it wasn't in my first
round that came afterwards and it since
it's already um
yeah it here nor there it doesn't it
didn't make it didn't seem to make a
difference so I just kept it there it's
it's two lines okay it's law so okay um
next question uh 10 theg5 or 10 the4 10
to
theg5 okay and any reason why you kept
that instead of switching to the ne4
which you had mentioned previously
mentioned previously that that was um um
that's not my decision and I didn't hear
anybody telling me to do it and um 10 to
theg5 was what how the rules first came
out um
and yeah they're um they're more
protective and it's it's where we should
be at it's still um a lot weaker than
many other states surrounding so if I
may ask representative germana how you
feel about
that yeah I believe it should be 10 to
the negative five okay okay you don't
feel that's uh too restrictive to get
past
or anything like that well when we uh
spoke with uh the department last year
when we were going through these bills
we have never been offered any evidence
empirical evidence that 10 to the neg5
is unworkable okay okay good and then
one quick question and I'll be done on
my end um does aquafer have any sort of
a definition if not in this in this bill
than in statute that we can link to
because there's concern the chairwoman
had some concern that aquafer is a
little too vague um and that um you know
there's there's a real definition of
aquafer it's not necessarily any any
body of water any stream of water so any
thoughts on that yes so every time there
was aquafer listed um it basically went
to
um existing aquafer drawn drinking water
Wells so pretty much every place that it
talks about an aquafer it then goes into
um aquafer drawn drinking water wells so
every single place that is referenced to
that except for like in the statement of
purpose it basically says in here
um drinking water sources our
environment including drinking water
wells per likes so
um when it was like in a in a general
general you know statement of purpose or
description but in every place where
it's talking about specifics it also it
always says Aqua for drawn drinking
water yeah so it sounds like it
qualifies that word a little bit um I'm
not a I'm not a legal scholar so I don't
know if that would be a problem or not
what are you what are your thoughts
representative J J well yeah I mean that
change makes sense to me my concern is
looking at the draft now uh page one
line 24
does say to any existing aquafer comma
drinking water well comma perennial
river so that didn't get changed to
aquafer drawn drinking water well which
is a different thing so that appears to
remain as yeah in two places OS did not
put that there and then in two other
places they did um she said it was
because of
um um grammatically
so I didn't fight with her yesterday on
it so I can tell them that I wanted
exactly how I worded it it was exactly
how it was sent to all of you so there's
two places that say that so um to be
sufficient located sufficiently close to
any existing aquafer drinking water well
that they she split it yeah it does it
seems like very different things there
it's like and so that's where I'm
concerned I'm I'm just wondering if
there is I don't know but if there is
anywhere in statute that we can link to
that defines what an aquafer is or if
not if we can put a um I mean I'm not an
expert on that stuff but if we could put
a definition of what an aquafer is um in
in this bill so that you know there's no
there's no um there's nothing because
the thing is is we we all really want
this bill to go through but I'm my my
fear is uh and maybe the fear of
chairwoman Aaron is that if there's some
sort of legal hangup that just caus a
problem um one thing I will say is we're
not going to exec this today um we've
got one more week before we have to act
on it so if there's any little things we
can flesh out we definitely should do
that I can I please yeah
so that definition is an aquafer is a
body of permeable Rock which can contain
or transmit groundwater so that's what
that I mean that's the definition I um
do you have be honest it shouldn't be an
it shouldn't be a problem in having that
in here like that but it can I can just
force OSS to go back to what I um what I
said I mean of course you're not going
to
um you're not going to be digging and
putting a landfill in an area where it's
going to transmit in the groundwater
because groundwater is what goes into
the drinking water wells so I mean it's
just basic water science yep
representative gerana anything to say
yeah could we ask the director to uh if
what his view of this subject
is have you been able to should I phrase
the question for you or have you been
able to piece it together from I think I
followed the discussion yes for the
record Mike whimet director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Dees um yeah I this issue of the use of
the term aquafer in the bill is
something that I believe I commented on
the first time the at the first hearing
for this bill and and my sense is that
you know I and I think what I tried to
convey then and um I think is important
to understand is that virtually all of
New Hampshire is underlaying by an
aquafer of some sorts we're blessed with
uh relatively per permeable soils and
relatively um uh fractured bedrocks so
that almost anywhere you want to if if
an individual residence wants to sink a
well and you know to install a well and
get enough water for one home they can
do it um that's not true for major
public water supply Wells you have to
look more carefully to site those
because you need much higher yields for
like a water system but as
representative Penza correctly pointed
out the term acfer is very broad it
basically says any formation that can
produce water and again you know in your
first level hydrogeology class when
you're studying this this particular
subject you learn that aquafer is in the
eyes of the beholder if if you know I
have a well in Bedrock the Bedrock under
my house is pretty competent I had to go
several hundred feet to get water but I
got it and I got enough for my house so
for me that's a bedar aquafer so I I
think that it's a
little with respect I think it's
Troublesome to use the term I don't know
that it really adds anything to the the
bill and if you use that term it is so
broadly read that you could conclude
that you can never site a landfill
anywhere because virtually everywhere in
New Hampshire could be considered an
aquafer follow yeah please I just want
if I would follow up in your
estimation does the phrase aquafer drawn
drinking water well is that more
appropriate in the text than the word
aquafer I would say it's redundant um I
think you could just say a drinking
water well because if there's a well
there and it's a drinking water well
it's clearly completed in an aquafer
yeah exactly okay all right thank you uh
representative uh Penza yeah I agree um
it was just trying to be specific in
there and so um and it made it easier
because any time there was the aaer I
had that in there so um I believe it's
two places where um that was done so I
think there's um we can make these are
very minor changes we can make that so
it's consistent throughout so what a
lither say um you know drinking water
wells and it doesn't need to necessarily
say aquafer at all in any place
throughout the bill so um do you have
extras of these yeah could you give one
to the director please
okay um real quick um do representatives
Gruber or uh Scully have anything they'd
like to ask or add
well well thank you Mr chair I I did
have a couple of questions so on line uh
page three lines 18 to
24 um this section has in my mind some
very subjective Lang wording um
significant history uh
serious
violations and uh I'm wondering if that
is too broadly worded or too open to
interpretation whose decides what's
significant whose decides what's serious
um It also says continued will full
non-compliance or unpaid fines I could
see situations where there would be
certain um companies that perhaps a fine
is levied against them and they wish to
contest it I'm wondering how we um
because maybe they think it's
unreasonable or unwarranted and so this
type of language in my mind would mean
that they're guilty until you know
proven innocent so I'm I'm a little
troubled with this this whole section I
maybe we can tighten up the language on
that um the on that same page lines one
123 I'm assuming there's a u practical
reason why that's been put in there
maybe it is just that you need to have
somebody there all the time I don't know
and maybe you know a landfill of any
size is going to have that done I my
question would be why why it's put in
there why it's needed um there was one
other thing well the only thing I'm I'm
really concerned about I I get the
five-year distance of travel estimate I
think that okay so now we're putting in
something that uh would give a
sufficient time to detect and perhaps do
something about it um the 1500 ft now
we're back to doing something very
prescriptive uh in terms of saying you
can't have it within that distance and
if we're going with a 5-year time of
travel there could be certain scenarios
I could imagine where you could be
within 1500 feet and still satisfy the
fiveyear um distance of travel estimate
so I I I'd like to really discuss why
we're deciding on both a Performance
Based criteria and a prescriptive one
all right thank you representative Penza
would you like to respond to that yes so
for the first question uh the reason why
is because that's how it currently is in
our in the rules and so it's basically
whichever is um is more protective so um
everything was supposed to be site
specific and that's not how the current
rules reflect that so um those are the
changes that are made just from that 500
is not enough so um that's why it's gone
up to, 1500 it was at 3,000 which when
the first map came out cuz I think
that's pretty important um you know when
when this first map came out um this was
based upon 3,000 and we still had uh
approximately um 45% of the state where
we could where you could still site a
landfill um yes of course you saw a lot
of blue but I think that that's very
important to note because um and now I
don't even know what that percentage is
so um in any case let me go back to so
that's why it's like that in regards
with setback in time of travel um lines
on page three lines 18 through
24 um that has already been buttoned up
like extremely buttoned up it was like
three paragraphs long that was
um um
very
um restrictive in regards with like
fines and all of that kind of stuff this
means that you have to have you have to
be a significant violator at that point
and who the um and who polices this
that's that would be the that would be
the department so um they're the ones of
course that are that are approving
permits or not and so already if you
look look
at lines 22 to 24 that's already part of
their permit application you can't have
an active lawsuit or anything like that
so that's already part of where they
would be denying a permit so that's a
given and then the yeah and then the the
top is basically I took you know two
paragraphs of information and brought it
down and I wanted it to be you know
where you know sign significant history
of repeated serious violations uh you
know because of course violations happen
they get fixed that happens all of the
time we're talking about you know
someone that's an abuser and so and I
think that it just um if if you feel
like that would need to be tightened up
if um if director whims looked at this
and and had concerns then I um you know
I would definitely make some changes
here but um I worked this really I
worked this a lot to try to make it so
it wasn't um where it could be frivolous
so
um thank you for that explanation I
would be interested to to hear what
director whimet has to say about that
language and then up at the top the last
question that you had in regards with
having at least one employee contracted
um power outages of course I they have a
dialer system this has been talked about
in um on the other side of the aisle
saying that it's not necessary we are
talking about a a an operation that
makes millions of dollars there needs to
be a person on site because if the power
goes out and that dialer doesn't work
which has happened we have had where
there is a spill that goes on over the
weekend and we don't you don't find out
about it until Monday so so from that
last you know last person on site on
Friday until Monday you could have three
days of incredible amounts of an
accident and that's it should not be
much at all um to have asking for one
live employee on site okay um we need to
speed things up thank you so much for
the um answers and explanations I do
want to let um representative grber um
have his say though thank you very much
um and thank you uh representative
Potenza for all these changes um the few
areas that I had concerns with with um
is the the aquafer issue and that's been
adequately addressed with drinking water
well which is great um also moving
towards the Performance Based system
with the five years before it could get
off site is I think it's really a great
way to deal with this because there's so
many variations of soils rather than a
prescriptive distance and including that
10 mile radius with the that landfill so
I I'm satisfied with where we are now
thank you all right thank you and then
um one last thing for everybody does
anybody else have anything else they'd
like to say before we finish here
no I just I just want to U mention that
it is possible we could either do that
now or during um a work session later
when everybody's here so that's I'll
leave that up to director whims if you'd
like to speak now or wait until the uh
work session it's at comm's pleasure I'm
happy to answer the representative's
question if he has one uh representative
senzu would you prefer his response to
be now or later it's totally fine I
think it's fine did you have a chance to
just read the paragraph okay yes I think
I understand what and I guess so I'm
looking at page for the record looking
at page three lines 18 through 24
correct which set out some uh
prohibitions on permitting for certain
violations and and and other conditions
I guess the first thing I would say you
know again we're not taking position on
the bill I'm asking I'm answering
because I've been asked um but but I
think director could you or pull it for
sure sorry about that um so on the lines
22 to
23 it just occurs to me that it isn't
always under the control of an
individual whether they're involved in
litigation anyone can file a suit for
any reason and so to say that a permite
could not be or an applicant could not
be granted a permit because they
involved in litigation it seems to me
that's disadvantaging an applicant for
something that they may not be able to
control so that's the only observation I
would make about that and then um with
regard to lines 18 through 19 where it
refers to um not issuing a permit um for
any applicant that has been found to
have significant history repeated
serious violations I certainly under
understand the intent
there and as representative Penza
correctly pointed out would be the
agency that would be implementing this
provision not entirely clear to me you
know where the break point is for
significant history of repeated
violations because these facilities are
complex it's possible to to commit
several violations over several days
when in fact the the the the applicant
may be making best efforts to to resolve
things um so I'm a little the only
concern I would have about that is how
we would decide in the event of an a
particular application where there was
some compliance here history what
constituted a significant history of
repeated violations and beyond that I
don't I don't have any observations on
that paragraph representative
Penza um thank you Mr um thank you
director whimet I I agree with you I
think that the I think that the um the
agency has they have their purpose right
so of course there's a balance uh you
know um Department of Environmental
Services of course is first and foremost
to be protecting um you know the
environment here for all of New
Hampshire and then of course we still
have to have a balance with industry and
all of that I get it I think that I
trust the agency to be able to make that
um um you
know those decisions especially where
you know let's say it's a new actor not
somebody that we already have a history
of that's working here in the state that
has a horrible track record with the
environment having that in there gives
you that discretion I think that's
important the second piece of that um
is the landfill related litigation I can
make that more specific because I know
that's already part of the permit right
now so I just want that I want that um I
want that in in basically in rules so
however that could be worded to be more
specific about what where it's pretty
much an automatic Denial on your part
right now um I wanted that to mirror
that so if that's not um that would be
on starting on line 22 so if that's not
as clear I'd be happy to clean that up a
little bit I thought it was enough
because it was you know landfill related
litigation but I can make that that can
be very more a lot more specific
thank you I I I do want to point out and
make sure the committee is aware there
are a couple Provisions in law and in
rule right now that that go to this one
of them is that we're not to approve a
permit unless or we to deny a permit if
we determine that an applicant does not
have the requisite expertise reliability
and integrity to operate a solid waste
facility that's in the rule um so we do
Implement that presently and then uh
also with regard to litigation
applicants required to sign a compliance
statement so um part part of that would
be if they are if there's an outstanding
administrative order against the
applicant then they need to demonstrate
how they're going to be in compliance
with it that they are either in
compliance with it or that if they are
not that they're that by virtue of
receiving an approval for the
application they would be coming they
would come into compliance with that
order so there are some Provisions that
that they're not they're not identical
to these but I don't want to tell you
that but there are some Provisions in
law and rule that that go to this
particular issue
okay thank you um with that being said I
think now would be a good time to wrap
it up um I'm real happy with the work
that's been done and um we've got some
good stuff we can tell during the work
session so with that I'll close the
hearing and uh thank you
everybody
okay
did um on HB um Bill the HB
e e
good morning everybody thank you for
waiting I'm sorry we're late for uh our
work our committee work session
uh I'd like to start the day with a
pledge of allegiance led by
representative
Freeman to United States
America stand One Nation God indivisible
with liy and justice for
allop sorry kissing chairs yeah kissing
chairs
okay this morning we have a a ahead of
us a work
session uh and we will be
discussing a number of
bills
whoops get myself situated
here okay
so we're going to start out uh our
discussion on HB
424 directing the Department of
Agriculture markets and food to create
forms for businesses to request
information about service animals and
establishing a committee to study the
protection of business owners from
requests to accommodate customers with
fraudulent or untrained service animals
we had this hearing last
week uh would anybody like to open
discussion about about uh this bill and
what we
heard representative wheeler good
morning morning Madam chair and thank
you for opening up the discussion I
think this bill presented a problem that
needs to be addressed but I'm not sure
that the legislature I'm actually
positive that the legislature can't
address this issue because of conflicts
with the Americans with Disabilities Act
on the federal level obvious obviously
those conflicts I think are a little
silly and the specifics around the
service dogs weren't well thought
through when that legislation was passed
leading to some of the problems that
were brought forward by the testimony
but other than potentially a study
committee and given the speaker and the
Senate presidents and the
leadership's directive around study
committees and wanting them not to move
forward unless absolutely necessary I'm
not sure this is the bium for a study
committee so I think given the only way
the legislature could move forward on a
policy like this is to have a study
committee that hones in hour after hour
as to specifics around what the
legislature could potentially do I I I
don't think that this legislation works
and I don't know if a study committee
given the as I said leadership's
directive around study committees is the
right way to move forward so maybe I
would suggest
sadly representative string is a friend
of mine an itl for this legislation but
I I think that might be the right way to
move forward that's my piece I tend to
agree with you thank you representative
Bixby yeah so um I think that uh I I
might um pose the issue of the problems
with trying to do a study committee a
little bit more strongly which is that I
think if we did a study committee we
would just find out what we already know
right now which is that we can't do
anything so I
okay yeah representative
King thank you madam chair uh there was
also discussion um before about
potentially um sending some sort of a
letter or house resolution to our
federal delegation and I'm I'm wondering
is that something that this bill could
be amended to do or is it something
would be better for him to just you know
we it itl this and then next year um
maybe representative Stringham and
others uh craft and house resolution
um well hold on one sec um I I believe
what we would need to do is itl this
bill and um representative Stringham is
certainly welcome to um write a letter
to the delegation or you know we can
also uh write a letter to the
delegation um in tandem to that I mean
we don't need to do anything
legislatively it's just represent Penza
um thank you madam chair I think I
offered to draft up something
specifically and um I've already started
that so I would be happy to do that and
um and then it could be worked on by of
course our committee and then and then
sent out um a letter specifically to the
federal delegation U pointing out some
of these issues I also think it's very
important for us to lean
on uh all of the tools that we currently
have the communication that comes out of
the um the disability um office out of
the governor's office so the commission
I think that's really important as well
um those notices are are very important
too I think telling people um what their
what questions they can ask and what's
what their rights are for for businesses
I think that's all very important as
well as um always protecting that
community
um as well so you don't um I think that
education is the key and there's been a
lot that's been done already um I think
it's just a matter of making sure that
we can utilize all those resources but I
think a letter um is is a great thing
saying hey can you guys button this up
on the federal
side yep
agreed any other questions or comments
about HB 424
um I just wanted to to uh represent
Bixby support the idea of the committee
sending a letter I think that's the
that's a relatively low overhead
approach to it rather than having to to
uh put in a a whole resolution and then
go through the whole um Bill LSR Bill
Etc Pro process on it because I think I
think that we we have the information we
need and a lot of from our committee
would probably be um sufficient okay
agreed okay uh no further discussion on
that uh I'm going to move on to
hb250 um we had a a um subcommittee
meeting on that bill and came out with
some language which I submitted to OS on
Friday
and I just got um the amendment back for
hb250 and unfortunately they inserted
the wrong Bill language into that
Amendment so I'm just now sending a
letter to O an email to OS to fix it
because they've mixed up the two bills
that were in OS so uh 250 hb250 will not
be um available for us to exec today
until they fix this um but basically um
what we had for um the
change to the muzzle
Bill let me just pull up
the language here that we came up
with okay let's see so while she's
looking for that I can just sort of give
a little sense of the logic behind it uh
what we heard in the hearing was there
was a concern that allowing a the
communities the general ability to
regulate everything about musling might
open it up to uh uh laws that
um uh ordinances that would uh regulate
specific require musling of specific
breeds and uh also musling of um of
hunting dogs and uh those were we saw
that both of those were potential
problems what we did was we added some
language uh referring to uh the
definition of a uh vicious or um un
vicious or whatever there are three
terms there uh dog that that are it's
already defined in statute and saying
that musling that they can make
ordinances uh for dogs uh that are
deemed to be uh vicious under this
statute
number yep um so what we what we
changed
was the language okay uh the language
that they had here was uh adding in to
RSA 466 colon 39
city or town bylaws the local governing
body may make such additional bylaws and
regulations concerning the licensing
they added the word
musling into and restraining of dogs as
it deems
reasonable and may a fix penalties etc
etc what we changed was instead of
inserting the word musling we inserted
the words musling of vicious dogs as
defined in RSA 466 colon 31
so that way we are restricting this uh
their ability to make any additional
bylaws and regulations regarding the
musling of vicious dogs and there's a
definition of what that is so it makes
this a little bit more clearer a little
bit more restricted um but also gives
them the the ability to do that and
that's what the the amendment is and
that's what I had hoped to get back from
uh OS this morning however that didn't
happen
so um I am sending a letter out to um
Courtney esbach to see if they can
straighten that out maybe we can have
that done today I don't know but if
not um both this bill and the bill they
mixed it up with we will recess those uh
or this bill was supposed to be exec
today on the list um we will have to
recess that till next week to have exact
out so that's where we are on hb250
any other questions or comments on that
bill okay seeing
none moving on to HB
262 relative to group licenses for
dogs uh any questions or comments about
um our hearing from last
Weekes I take this sure um so uh from
previously looking at the group dog
license statute
um I uh I'm aware that there is a a
certain amount of disparity in terms of
Licensing fees uh
so um the licensing fee for if you have
you can have a group license if you have
five dogs or more uh if you have three
or four dogs the sum of the fees for
those dogs will exceed the amount of
money that it that it costs to get a
group license for uh five dogs to
infinite number of dogs uh and uh so my
initial thought was that this bill might
address it uh the bill was a mess it
didn't make any sort of numerical sense
and the the bill sponsor didn't show up
to uh explain what was going on or offer
anything any sort of resolution uh I
don't think this is the work the kind of
work we need to take on as a committee
even if we think that it might be a good
idea uh so I think this is just an
itl okay any other question or
comment seeing none and and I agree with
your assessment representative Bixby
thank you so much you're
welcome uh we heard last week also hb401
relative to animal testing funded by New
Hampshire State funds would anybody care
to make any comment about that uh
representative German
germana either way either way thank you
very much Madam chair I I just want to
say very quickly this seems to me the
very definition of a a a solution in
search of a
problem um I don't think there's
any reason to believe that we need to do
this and so absent that I can't see
anything other than
it thank you I know know that
um uh we have a federal Animal Welfare
act that um our facilities have to
comply with and um I think that that
Federal Animal Welfare act also takes
care of what this bill is trying to
address representative Freeman thank you
madam chair and and I and thank you for
that stal and M Thunder thank you very
much while I wasn't physically at the
hearing I did watch it and um I I was
struck by the fact that no one could
come up with any clear answers about if
we're doing animal testing in New
Hampshire is this a problem so given
that I I couldn't support legislation
that again as representative Jama stated
is you know a solution looking for a
problem so again if this becomes a
problem in the state naturally we should
address it but I don't think at this
time that would be prudent and in so far
as um animal what cosmetic cosmetic
testing I in New Hampshire the only
Cosmetic Company I know of is Badger and
I know that they are absolutely uh
cruelty-free
company so okay uh any other question or
comment representative King thank you
madam chair um I think the most
interesting part of this bill was was
um was the recordkeeping requirements
the idea that if there is any animal
testing that they need to
sort of alert the house or the the
Senate um I'm not too concerned about
the animal testing because like was
brought up in public hearing we don't
really know if that happens but when it
comes to just regular animal testing I I
personally would be shocked if there
wasn't something like that going on in
the biology department or some
Department of one of the universities I
mean when I was at University you know I
wasn't I didn't do it personally but I
visited these labs and you know there's
a lot of animal testing going on so it
would be I suppose nice to know if that
was happening in the state of New
Hampshire that we had a way to look and
figure out and kind of at least at least
understand what's going on and and then
worry about if we want to do something
about it unfortunately you know a lot of
this bill contains stuff that you know
like uh representative germana said is
sort of a pro a solution in search of a
problem um I I would hope that if we do
itl this that maybe the sponsor will uh
bring it back another year and and
narrow down the focus to just learning
more about what sort of animal testing
is going on in the state and then maybe
doing something about that and not not
have so much language specifically just
about um product testing which may not
even be happening thank you
representative um Bixby yes so uh as it
stands right now excuse me as it stands
right now um any
uh institution that is getting Federal
money
for uh doing uh research that involves
animals uh is required to have an
Institutional Animal Care and use
committee uh
and uh the proceedings of the animal
care and youth committee are public
records and you can request uh
information from the IU of any of any uh
institution that's doing research that
involves animals uh and uh and that you
know that is available as a public
public record right now I don't know uh
exactly you know whether there's already
website that is up that sort of lists
everything that they're doing but um
that that is public that is public
record it is available right
now okay thank you representative Bixby
any other representative
Penza thank you madam chair um I had an
extensive conversation with
the some of the people that were here
testifying sponsor co-sponsor um
and although I I like the idea of of
saying not New Hampshire and I there's
that's that piece um I don't I think
coming to the committee I think it was
very important for them to at least have
basic information and that information
is available so for example any single
um even private business here uh
Corporation in New Hampshire that is
doing any sort of animal testing at all
um they have Labs all of that stuff has
to be licensed so I said have you you
know go to DHHS find out whoever is
doing not necessarily for any product
testing but whatever kind of testing
that they might be doing um and that
would include of course you know the
federal piece with the university stuff
that's that's easy to get that kind of
information in regards with the federal
stuff so I recommended that they would
do that immediately and get that kind of
information to say okay well there we
know for fact there's 10 facilities that
are doing animal testing on X Y and Z
that would be really good information to
have that the committee would have so I
I asked them to follow up with that type
of
information um you know I know we do
pass bills that make a statement um the
reporting mechanism I don't agree with
either I don't think it kind of makes
sense um but I do um it would be nice to
know what's going on in New Hampshire so
um I don't think this bill is ready for
prime time yet I think that I think we
need the data and it would be really
nice to have that kind of information
and I think that's something that
hopefully uh the bill uh sponsor
co-sponsors would be willing to gather
that and provide that to the committee
um to move forward with something if
it's necessary I don't think there's a
problem with saying hey we don't want
that in New Hampshire there's many other
states it's um it's um as our as the kid
Governor came here and and testified as
well um you know we don't want any sort
of uh unnecessary product testing on
animals there's a lot of companies that
are very much against that of all that
ethical treatment and um so it'd be nice
to have a statement but I think it just
has to I think there has to be more work
done in this space and just more
research and information that we could
have thank you representative
Howard um I thought that we that our
researcher did a pretty exhaustive
search right to to find any evidence
that that that was out there so and I
think that also in the testimony um they
they had also done research so I really
think that it's not it's not it's making
a statement about something that's just
not happening would be sort of a waste
of our time so thank you representative
Bixby so I think that some of the laws
that are in other states uh
restricting uh Cosmetics that have been
tested on animals uh is uh I think that
what that is done is What's Done in
those States or at least some of them is
to have a ban on sales of products and
that would which would essentially not
make it you know just something that's
produced in the state but something
that's produced in another state but
sold into the state and there are third
party organizations that certify
products as being not tested on animals
Etc um if another bill that had this
general purpose was to come forward I
think that it would it would make more
sense to look at those other states that
have a banon sales and do it in terms of
a sales a sales ban rather than a um for
things that are tested on animals rather
than trying to figure out what's being
you know how the animal testing might be
happening in New Hampshire or not uh and
uh I think that that's also a bill that
would probably end up going to Commerce
rather than us so uh so which which
means that which also means that we
can't amend this bill to do that because
we had another bill that would have
moved it into Commerce territory last
year and we weren't allowed to do that
so
okay any other question or comment
regarding this
bill all right seeing none I think we're
going to move
on um the next bill is HB
616 relative to the confiscation of
animals from persons suspected of or
charged with abuse of animals um we had
testimony from our hearing we had um
input from
various uh parties on
this
and so just represent Bixby yeah so um
the the incorrectly produced uh
Amendment does that actually have the
most current language for 616 in
it I haven't looked it over but it looks
like it does okay so it might make sense
to pass that out with the caveat that is
in that in in fact not the right bill
number but it will give us the right
stuff to discuss yeah so if we want to
talk about it sure so let me uh let me
pass half half this way half that
way
yeah
yeah give one to uh the commissioner
Jasper please
okay okay
um Madam shair yes are you
gonna if we have any extra copies please
give one to uh Mr Johnson in the
back so we're not voting on this
today um
but I want everybody to see we had
Incorporated changes that um the
commissioner has requested as well
as changes that uh from
testimony and uh I mean we can can kind
of give you a moment to look through it
and if you have any
[Music]
questions we
can discuss it
sure representative King you have a
question thank you madam chair um on
page two uh lines 17
um it says no confiscated animal shall
be altered prior to conviction and I'm
just wondering if we're going to be able
to have any sort of language that would
also deal with euthanization you know I
know that they it was claimed that you
know if an animal had been seized and
was suffering that they would euthanize
it um which seems very drastic to me I'm
just wondering if there was anything
that could be done to protect against
that as I understand part of being Al
would also include
euthanasia so that that's an extreme
alteration represent Penza just a quick
question on that
um was that already
in um 17 line 7 page two lines 17
through 19 was that in the original or
is that part of the amendment I'm trying
to remember if the no confiscated animal
shall be altered prior to a conviction
for abuse or neglect under this section
without the notorized authorization of
the owner from whom the animal was
confiscated was it worded like that in
the original or was
that well that wasn't in there at
all it was not in there at all okay
because I know we talked about that's
perfect I like that language a lot um
where I have a oh represent King I'm
sorry uh Madam chair um are you happy
with the language that OSS has done or
do you feel that there is still any more
work that needs to be done or changes
that that needs to be made to what
they've
done I think this looks fine uh in in so
far as uh incorporating the uh comments
that we've had from the commissioner and
Farm Bureau uh as well as um uh you know
folks from uh the animal
protection
section um representative ktoa thank you
Ma Madame chair I'm just looking at um
on page
one uh line 13 um and I was just
wondering if that could be clarified it
says no animal shall be confiscated
unless a person is charged under this
under the section in line 14 except when
the officer believes that the animal's
life is in
danger
um so my question is is do they have
sole discretion there does a
veterinarian have to be called in
because it doesn't look like that it
just says except
when so I'm I'm I just want a little bit
of clarification on that line if I could
please okay so the line above it uh
indicates that an investigating officer
would be accompanied by a state
veterinarian or their design Who Shall
Set probable cause criteria so I would
imagine that um the uh investigating
officer would have someone with them to
advise them as to whether the animal uh
the animal's life is in danger or not
I understand that but it does say accept
and so that is where I'm questioning
that the accept is in cases I guess of
uh protective custody um commissioner
would you like to come up and perhaps
clarify that or suggest where we may add
some language or
something thank you madam chairman
members of the committee I think you do
have to give the officer that discretion
and he would have to justify at a later
time why he believed the animal's life
was in danger we you are not going to be
able to get the state V veterinarian or
his design 247 365 days a year there are
going to be times and there even if
somebody was going to come say from two
hours away if he was in a situation
where he believed that that animal's
life was in imminent danger I don't
think any of us would want to want to
say oh well just leave them there to die
without the exception language that is
what you're
doing um so that's why I suggested that
language recognizing there are going to
be extenuating circumstances the officer
would have to justify later why he
believed that to be the case
representative K thank you madam chair
commi commissioner when when you were
just speaking you said a key word there
and I think it would be important
imminent and I think that really needs
to be put in there um would you have
objection no I I certainly don't have
any objection and and Madam chairman
while I'm at the table I I think that in
the drafting of this amendment
everything REM uh relative to the
paramutual and the racing is um no
longer in the amendment would stay in
law so if you just double check on that
because there seems to be something
there unless I'm missing it but I will I
will double check that thank you
yeah okay hold on one
second and you wanted to include say
imminent
danger okay um representative
Penza thank you madam shair so line 14
will go I just wanted to clarify so
believes that the animal's life is in
imminent danger perfect and then
is there a way to connect the two so no
animal shall be confiscated unless a
person is charged under this section
except when the officer slash you know
um um State veterinarian or their design
believes that the animal can you
qualify um the officer with the vet in
that or is that just automatically known
because it's mentioned previously I
think it's mentioned previously
I think there are actually two as
aspects to that one is it's because it's
in the sentence right before that that
this they're doing it under the advice
that's fairly clear the other is that in
terms of actually making the
determination it has to be the law
enforcement officer because the State
Vet does not have that's right has that
Authority Poli policing Powers
yeah how I have one other piece um
so it's on it's page two
um lines 20 21 and
22 uh I think that um the changes here
are great there I think that's missing
one piece um there is
so besides a um soliciting of donations
if if no one has been charged with a
crime and an entity that was involved in
in confiscating animals is is putting it
out there on their website or social
media basically um convicting that
person which causes threats and all of
these other things that happen um you
know because of course it's the court of
public opinion is there any way to have
a sentence in there that's not just
solicit donations
but correct that are basically you know
um convicting these owners and puming
these owners before they were even
charged or anything like that like
before I don't know I just that to me is
just as
bad I mean it was clear that um the
situations that we heard and I've heard
of others of the level of threats that
came from Outsiders in the community was
horrible I mean it'll destroy people's
businesses and livelihoods docks of
family that's just not okay especially
if there was no conviction nothing was
was set in stone there's no you know to
try to protect that while du process and
the whole thing is going on nobody
should be able to take investigative
information put it online and then have
the public go after them with pitor
works right so actually there is another
section that addresses that which is on
page three line
18 uh in order to protect the Integrity
of a complaint of complaint
investigations an appropriate law
enforcement officer shall require any
person or the their designated agent
called upon to take possession of any
animal seized or to assist during any
complaint investigation to sign a
binding non-disclosure agreement
intended to protect any shared or
confidential confidential information
against unauthorized use pending the
final adjudication or dismissal of such
complaint providing that the information
may be disclosed only to officials with
a need to know who are subject to
confidentiality confident
confidentiality
obligations so that
basically uh that that basically gets it
exactly what you were talking
about yeah um representative Scully well
well thank thank you madam chair this is
definitely going in the right direction
um so is there any functional difference
between confiscation of an animal taken
into protective custody I see the words
used you know in confiscation in one
place in protective custody in
another so as I understand protective
custody is a more immediate action where
the animals are taken right away this is
in the case of if the um if the owner is
not around or not home
uh confiscation so protective custody is
a form of confiscation let's put it that
way okay may I ask one other question
please yes um I now again I have to read
this again uh carefully but I did have a
question um I don't know if we have any
prohibition uh regarding allowing the
comp the person who files the complaint
from also participating in the
investigation whether that would uh
constitute a conflict of interest that
was that's on uh page three line
14 oh wonderful thank you for pointing
that out
y representative
germana thank you madam chair CH chair
pardon me gosh I can't get rid of this
cough um so I have a question about page
two lines 17 to 19 that representative
Penza referred to earlier and this is a
process question I'm just trying to to
Think Through I understand the purpose
uh of this section so no confiscated
animal shall be altered prior to
conviction I you know I think there's a
consensus that euthanizing an animal
fits under you know that term altered
but here's my question thinking about
the how long it can take to get a
conviction of somebody and if we're
talking about somebody of course someone
is not guilty until proven uh or is not
yeah guilty until they're proven
innocent but if if there is an animate
pardon me
if if they're yeah well I'm saying that
they're not presumed guilty right so we
can't assume that but if you have a case
where an animal as judged by maybe it
could even be a couple of different
veterinarians or whatever if an animal
is in really really bad shape I would
hate to think that an animal would have
to continue suffering throughout the
entire length of proceedings until a
conviction is secured and you may have a
case of legitimate abuse where an animal
is really really suffering and by the
time you get to conviction conviction
I'm assuming it could be many weeks or
months so I don't know if it's possible
I hate the idea but I'm a little that's
what concerns me is that we may have
animals who are deeply suffering and if
there's a way to say that maybe two
veterinarians or whatever might concur
that euth in Asia is an appropriate uh
step to take that's my only concern it's
not about assuming anyone's guilty it's
just a concern for an animal who may be
really suffering and may have to suffer
for weeks or months represent ktoa thank
you madam chair I think when we're
dealing with animal cases the court
hearing has to be expedited so um they
get a quicker court hearing than you
know just you or I um you know we have
that is in our rsas that they have to be
heard very quickly so that then a judge
is already involved within I think it's
7 to 14 days all right thank you very
much help representative uh Bixby uh
just a a caveat about that and and I
think that maybe the um commissioner
might want to weigh in on this because I
think he might know this a little bit
more thoroughly than I do but um I
believe that there what is required
within 15 days is a status hearing and
that does not actually uh establish uh
that doesn't establish the con the final
conviction and just as a way of figuring
out what should be happening with the
animals uh and I'm not sure what the I I
it's been a while since I've really
looked at this carefully so I'm not sure
what entirely is covered under the
status hearing could you clarify that
for us
commissioner I don't have any particular
knowledge of the status here and what I
can tell you is that once an animal is
seized the original owner is no longer
in charge of that animal we have the
cost of care fund which has criteria set
out for how much money that we can
expend for that animal and I don't have
all of it in in front of
me my my understanding is that if an
animal is suffering and is not in a in a
position where we can uh relieve that
suffering the animal will be euthanized
because at that point it is not anyone
else's property it has become the
property essentially of the state and so
it animals are not allowed to suffer in
in that situation the animals that we
can care for during that period and can
be you know rehabilitated if necessary
will be but animals that are in in a
state of suffering would be euthanized
and in this paragraph too it also says
that um you would have to get notorized
authorization from the owner so if the
animal is suffering and they want to
euthanize it they
would talk to the owner of the animal
and I would
imagine proceed with getting the
notorized authorization to do so
represent
Penza yeah I think that uh what you just
said is key because from listening to
the
testimony um with some of the animals
that were put down that weren't
necessarily um um in distress they were
only in distress because you know they
they they didn't have were nursing that
kind of thing so I think that the piece
there that you're talking about um is
important
because maybe that is where a solution
comes in where I can take care of my
animals you don't need to euthanize them
that type of thing so in regards with
that that
notorized so um there was another
question that representative Scully had
and I just wanted to answer that um I'm
not sure if you were part of the hearing
where the protective custody piece so
for example um I didn't realize this too
that sometimes if somebody's sick an
owner could die or something like that
and the animals are left in home that
that piece there that protective custody
so I know they're sometimes used
interchangeably but where the like the
department or law enforcement is coming
in to take animals sometimes it's just
because you know God forbid the owner
could be in a car accident or something
like that could happen so then the
animals are taken care of fed and things
like that not home um alone and that
kind of piece so there's that part of
that type of protective custody where
it's just unforeseen circumstances that
take
place okay represent King thank you
madam chair I'd like to get back to the
questions representative germana raised
because I think it is an important one
you know the answer we just kind of got
was that well you can get authorization
from the owner but that assumes that the
owner has the animals welfare in mind if
it's if it's an abuse case the animal
the owner might not give the permission
because he was abusing the animal
anyways and so just let it keep
suffering so that is a problem I I I see
I thank you for bringing that up um and
then um in regards to this uh the
commissioner sort of answered um in a
legalistic way as far as who has custody
but I'm curious um a lot of the changes
that we're seeing in this amendment my
understanding is that they were done
with um input from the commissioner so
I'm curious if the commissioner had
anything to do with this line and if so
what his thoughts are on it not from a
legal necessarily point of view but just
from a practicality point of
view thank you and if I if I may when I
gave the answer I wasn't thinking of new
nine I was aware of it I don't fully
support this because the owner the
previous
owner has had that right taken away from
him but if the committee feels strongly
about this then I would implore you just
for the reasons that you heard to add
except in the case of a court order
because obviously um these animals were
not well cared for and you're exactly
right that somebody may say no you know
you you continue to deal with them so I
think there needs to be the opportunity
for uh the state to move forward and say
this animal needs to be put down for its
own own welfare and so representative
Bixby so
uh I'm not sure if you have the answer
to this uh right in front of you but um
so in current law uh after the um after
there's been that status hearing uh
there's a uh line five in so um so Roman
3A on number five is no custodian of an
animal confiscated under under this
section shall spay or neuter or
otherwise permanently alter the
confiscated animal in his or her customy
custody pending the final disposition of
the case unless a treating veterinarian
deter determines that such procedure is
necessary to save the life of the animal
so that's current law does uh line n
here replace that or is it added to that
I I am not sure um you know as I said
I'm not the biggest fan of of uh section
nine I think that you know the current
law probably covers that and frankly I
was not thinking of the altered
including youth in Asia um I certainly
see how that could be interpreted that
way so again if you're going to leave
that and that's the interpretation let's
not make something else subject to
debate because we know although the
committee may feel that way you end up
to court and you know could be well you
know euthanasia is not altering the
animal it's euthanasia but uh right so
so so in in terms so you think that in
terms for clarity we should add
euthanasia specifically there and we
should also add something about a court
order potentially being uh an
alternative if
the owner is being really uncooperative
and it's really medically necessary I I
would agree with that yes thank you
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair I'm wondering can we hear from
maybe Chief suckling from Alexandria or
Sheriff fright from bellnap I know
they're here I wonder if they have
something to add to this conversation
sure please have a seat and introduce
yourself let us know who you are and
where you're from so much app I
appreciate being here today um so my
name is Dave suckling I'm the chief of
the Alexandria Police Department thank
you very much for the mild introduction
um I'm on the governor's Commission of
the Humane treatment of animals I'm
currently getting appointed to that I'm
in the process of that but I've been
appointed that by the New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association and and I
speak also for the New Hampshire Chiefs
of Police Association while I'm here
today uh we we oppose this bill and and
I can go through why
um we just got handed the new one so I'm
a little on the back foot with us this
morning but I will tell you a few things
I've been involved in animal cruelty
cases since the day that I started in
law enforcement there's only one thing
more emotional than law enforcement and
it's probably domestic violence people
are very passionate about their animals
and I understand that completely and and
because that people also don't see the
degradation of their animals that that
we see when we arrive on scene for the
first time um I've worked livestock
cases I've worked um animals uh cats and
dog cases I've I've worked a lot of them
and you guys were asking before about
the process through the courts and how
it takes a long time um I'll just
highlight a case that we did uh several
week uh two weeks ago probably I think
now um we took a dog from from a house
we were there to serve some paperwork on
the owner and the dog came out of a
kennel and it was terrible it was a rot
wheeler it was about I I don't know 20
30 lbs underweight we seized the dog
immediately on the spot it had no water
it was living in 10 and minus
temperatures um it's pretty apparent to
us pretty quickly what a what a abused
dog looks like or an unfair dog looks
like um we seized the dog um we didn't
arrest the person at the time which is
contrary to what you guys are suggesting
in this bill and there's a reason for
that we're a small Police Department
there's two of us and our job that day
was
yeah um so this bill is dealing mostly
entirely with livestock so I don't know
where it's coming and and can
representative kto has a question for
you yes you mentioned that you are
working on getting appointed to the
Humane commission but are you testifying
on their behalf because no I'm not I'm
just telling you that I've been
appointed to that by the Association no
I'm definitely not but my my point was
I've been appointed to that by the
chiefs of Police Association that was
right but I just want to make sure that
everyone on in in the on the committee
and in the audience knows that you are
not speaking on behalf of the commission
no I'm definitely not thank you okay
anybody has a question for um can I talk
about an animal cruelty case that I did
that was livestock if you'd rather me
talk about that because it's it's
relevant it's very relevant to what
you're talking about you're talking
about seizing animals um without an
arrest being made we've done that many
times and we have to sometimes because
we're such a small agency and most of
the
agencies yeah representative Freeman yes
Madam chair while I appreciate um uh the
chief coming in front of us I I do
believe that this is a work session and
not a hearing so I I think we need to
keep within those parameters in order to
find a solution I would love to ask the
chief any questions and I think there's
many on this committee who would like to
but I think it's important that we stay
along those lines yes I agree and um so
certainly if anybody has any questions
for um
I'm sorry I missed your name uh Chief
David sackin you can call me David fine
yeah Chief David sackin um please we can
ask them now representative
Penza uh thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so you
haven't been able to read the um the
changes that were made I had read the
one before today I'm not sure which
version that was and I apologize for
that but I haven't read much of the one
today so my question is can you give a
spefic specific example of where um you
think there are some problems with this
bill from an experience so let's say you
just said you had a a livestock um
experience um so it specific speaking
directly to the bill where do you see an
inherent problem right now um one of the
parts of the bill that I see a problem
and I and I think it's in the new part
like I said I've just had 10 minutes
with it um is assuming that there's a
theft if we take an animal without
charging someone that's hamstringing us
that's that's really I I think you guys
are looking for law enforcement to be
involved in in animal cruelty and I
think that's almost threatening in a way
to us that that if we don't arrest
someone at the time then that could be
considered unauthorized taking I I we
don't like that okay representative
wheeler thank you madam chair I'm
wondering thank you Chief suckling for
coming before us thank you does the
language in the first section line 14
around except when the officer believes
that the animal's life is in danger does
that at all alleviate any concerns that
you or your organizations have around
not being able to have the discretion
you need in these cases where I I think
that works for us generally speaking it
gives us some exent circumstances that
we can work around yes so it might if I
could Madam chair sure it might move you
from being opposed to this Bill to maybe
being neutral and not taking a position
you're talking about a small part of a
larer bill I would say this part of it
is is
adequate representative kto you had a
question no you're good representative
Howard thank you madam chair um so to I
actually had the same point as as
representative wheeler but I also um I
also wanted to comment that the
difference between that the last bill
and this one is that the big gap that
got closed was in precisely the lines
that we're talking about um and and so
you might want to take a closer look
because I think that I had the same
problem that you did before that there
was there seem to be some steps missing
and some and and some things that were
out of order and I really think that
these lines uh solve that problem okay
all right thank you sir thank you for
having me we uh so I as I see it in
lines 17 to 19 on page two regarding
confiscating animal uh no confiscated
animal shall be altered prior to
conviction for abuse Etc that
section needs some work so we'll have to
work on that represent
Penza so um based thank you madam chair
based upon what the commissioner stated
um and I don't want to put words in your
mouth wherever he is
um that can be fixed in in regards we
can keep that and the wording can change
by just adding um a court order
basically a court order would Trump um
the in a sense the notorized
authorization correct that's what I was
hearing from that
okay
okay uh representative Scully thank you
madam chair yeah yes speaking to that
that uh Clause I would say in case
except in the case of a court order no
confiscated animal sh be altered I think
I'd like to see or euthanized in there
just so there's no um how would one say
it
uh ambiguity that's the exactly the word
thank thank you very much uh I would
point out I think this is very important
because if somebody was being charged
with animal cruelty I could see them
withholding authorization to euthanize
an animal because they might consider
that proof of the fact that they were
conducting animal cruelty so the court
order is a very important um addition
okay um representative Howard neena oh
you you had your hand up I'm sorry thank
you mad still have your hand up okay
thank you madam chair I'm not going to
take it personally that I put my hand up
a half dozen times sorry it is what it
is people don't look over this this way
um I what what I'm hearing my apologies
no no not necessary um what I think
might help us address that issue with
euthanization is um on line 31 page one
no custodian of an animal confiscated
under this section s spay on no authoriz
permanently alter the confiscated animal
in his or her custody pending final
disposition of the court case unless a
treating veterinarian deems such a
procedure necessary to save the life of
the animal or in the case of emminent
suffering euth in Asia so that might
address what our concerns are about it
make it a little cleaner and a little
more succinct thank
you so you would add in the words or in
the
case okay got
it represent Howard thank you madam
chair I'm a little bit confused by
getting authoriz notorized authorization
from the person who has has um committed
the you know negligence or or abuse in
order to you know in order to take these
next steps um so I'm I'm just wondering
if that's the person that we need to
that we need to get the final word
from
well
yeah representative kto you had a i
comment I I did um based on on what uh
representative Howard was saying because
as we know we just had a case um where
animals were
confiscated um and you
know if someone doesn't know the owner
doesn't notorized that and sometimes the
owner understands the animals better
and so I I'm a little concerned about
that but I think with the cleaning up of
a lot of this it will help mitigate that
portion of it but I think it's important
to note that um except in like as
representative rman said extreme
suffering um you know the owner should
have a say
because we're innocent until proven
guilty um and we have to go under that
assumption if we're going to follow the
follow the
law but represent vix and then Penza so
um I think one thing that is still a
little bit um
unclear uh is the difference between
confiscation and uh and protective
custody and uh as the as the both both
as it stands in current law and as it is
this amendment is written they are
distinct things but it is but it is not
actually defined anywhere really
outright this is what confiscation is
versus this is what protective custody
is I think we might want to include in a
definition section in this chapter uh a
definition of custody uh protective
custody and a definition of confiscation
just so that is that is really clear
when it's being read
because
um when when an animal is taken into
protective custody it is not yet it is
not yet confiscated uh it is still
um there there the uh so the
um
so uh under uh in in section two unless
charges have been filed or this is lines
33 and 34 on line on page two unless
charges have been filed or a warrant
establishing probable cause has been
issued the animal or animal shall be
returned to the owner or their design or
caretaker upon request
so that you so at that point uh if there
is then if charges are then filed
or there's a warrant for probable cause
that at that point the protective
custody gets converted to
confiscation and which is which ties
into what's happening in
um in on page three in uh uh line 24 the
confiscation of any animal or animals
without a charging of the owner or
without or caretaker or without a
warrant specifying probable cause under
paragraph 4 shall be theft uh by
unauthorized taking so uh that's that's
where the um we where there needs to be
so the the common sense understanding of
confiscation is different from what is
actually happening in the law I think
having some definitions uh at the
beginning of the section might help
clarify that um
commissioner thank you madam chairman I
am very much afraid you are going to
make perfect the enemy of of good or
however that phrase goes when we had our
meeting months ago that's when I
suggested there are a lot of problems in
this section that we need to have a
study committee but there are things
that are very important now and I think
and that's why I'm not a a big fan of
putting nine or 10 in even at at this
particular time I think we you need to
focus on fixing the problems and you
just heard from the the chief and
clearly that's where the problem was in
in Lee they don't understand that you
can't seize an animal now without um
filing charges
and that the protective custody even
though not as well defined but in your
fix does Define it better it always said
you you know you have to leave the
notice where they can you don't do that
if somebody is there and so I think it
was always clear in the
law um to most people that that was
there but now we get into these
definition this should be the purpose of
the study committee all these other
tangental issues should be what you put
in the study please I'm I'm imploring
you to fix the problems that exist now
don't try to fix everything now or you
are going to lose this maybe not in the
house but you send it to the Senate and
you're probably going to lose it and
they're just going to go with the study
committee we need fixes that happen now
I just would say please keep keep the
fixes simple
okay sure just question I I think that I
I I appreciate your thoughts on that and
I think that this could in fact wait for
the study committee y represent Penza
thank you madam chair um I still think
it's important to have um you know I did
another bill definitions I think are key
so having certain things um defined in
there so for example so we wouldn't have
to places where it talks about being
altered um that includes of course
euthanasia so I think having those types
of definitions in there are important um
not having you know taking the
commissioner's point you know if we're
going to leave some things out because
it's we're trying to bite off too much
at this point I get it but I I think
that having um right out in the
beginning some definitions is is really
helpful and it also helps to um have
less words so if if altered means all of
those things then you don't need to say
um and we already know that it means all
of those things but I think it's it's
good to have those definitions that are
in there thank you representative King
thank you madam chair uh with all du
respect to the commissioner I
respectfully disagree I think we're
really close on this to be honest and I
feel like I mean I'm not the one doing
the heavy lifting but I just feel like
with all the notes that have been taken
all the work that we've put into the
things that need to be changed I feel
like within the week OS could put them
in there and um and I think by next week
I think this could be solved and I think
if we had a study committee I mean the
amount of time and effort that that
study committee would have to do to
catch up to what we've already done and
the leg work we've already done in this
committee I feel like I that would be
kind of sad so for me I personally would
prefer we just forge on and see if we
can get this done by next week and if we
can great if not if you really feel like
at the end of the next week it really
does need still a lot of work then then
maybe but you know worst case scenario
and I don't think we should rely on it
because I think we should feel confident
about the bill before we passed it but
if we passed it and it went to the
Senate and then we found out oh there's
a one little tweak here or there Senate
could fix it and you know it does happen
where Sometimes some something will pass
the house and then the sponsor goes to
the Senate and says vote this down
because I found things that are wrong
with it that does happen too so I I
personally I think it would be sad if we
sent this to a study committee and lost
so much of this this actually has a
study committee included in the language
okay but
um all this the all the work that we've
already put into it um I don't think we
should give up on that no represent
Bixby so I had a comment which the chair
already made for me oh sorry and no
problem and I have a question for the
chair uh in in her role as the uh Prime
sponsor of the amendment which is um how
much of a how much of a lift is it for
you to do uh summer all the things we've
talked about uh I I I'm just I want I
don't want to put I don't want this to
uh sort of be an infinite regress of
just adding one more thing and one more
thing and one more thing uh I think some
of the things we've talked about Pro
probably are not a very heavy lift I
just want to get a sense of where you
are in terms of what makes sense to do
now and and what yeah well the the thing
the things that we T talked about uh
putting in fixes for you know with a
imminent danger and um talking about
well we have
to look at section nine a little bit for
the wording but
um I I'm I don't know how comfortable I
am in putting in definitions right now I
think that's something that uh with the
study committee that's included in this
um bill we can refine at some point
later on when we do the study committee
that sounds good to me and another thing
to remember is that when we do the study
committee if we look at it again and
decide that uh what we wrote this week
is not as concise or perfectly worded as
it needs to be that's something we can
take up with a study committee uh but we
want we need to have some changes now in
order to make sure that we don't have a
um a a one-year lag in terms of getting
these protections into into into place I
agree representative wheeler thank you
madam chair I don't want to overstep my
bounds here as a freshman on this
committee but I do see that we're only
five minutes under an hour on this
discussion with five minutes left uh
five bills left only 20 minutes left on
the I would like to move on thank you
thank you I think we have uh a good
amount of uh you know some some things
that needed some editing so I will take
care of those uh and of course uh you
know we have the issue of it not being
uh the the right proper Amendment to the
proper bill so um and anyway uh thank
you all for your work and comments on
this and uh we will move on to HB
152 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive rodent
traps um I don't know we've we've kind
of talked about this already I don't
know that anybody is uh really changed
in their view of this so I think we
don't need to talk about it more now
we'll have a vote in hour or so and
we'll what happens will happen okay
thank you all right moving on to uh HB
251 the infamous squirrel
bill um I have an amendment that was uh
sent out by representative Spain and I'm
going to pass it along to
everybody um there's two pages here
please take one of each one is the law
uh regarding fishing game and the other
is can I have a copy too um and the
other is the section 201 colon 14 and
the other is the amendment that he's
offering up and pretty much what I want
to say about this is that the amendment
that uh representative Spain is offering
up is is at least to
allow people who have raccoons and gray
squirrels who are moving into New
Hampshire if they have them as pets
already in another state that if they
move into the state they that they may
bring their pets with them to the state
of New Hampshire um it it reads raccoons
and gray squirrels may be possessed as
companion animals without a permit from
the Department if a person relocates
from a state with a raccoon or gray
squirrel where it is legal to keep a
raccoon or gray squirrel so long as such
animal is up to date on any vaccines
required the raccoon or a gray squirrel
shall not be confiscated or euthanized
without the permission of the owner
nothing in this paragraph shall be
construed as enabling or trapping
breeding and sale of raccoons and gray
squirrels so this would go
into um The Fish and Game General
Provisions uh import possession or
release of Wildlife and so I'd like to
open up some discussion I'm I'm actually
fairly okay with this I think um
this takes out the piece having to do
with fish and game Rehabilitation and if
they can't rehabilitate the animal to
set it back into the wild uh where they
would be able to give it out for
adoption to someone else so that piece
is all been cut out um all this allows
for is for someone who has a raccoon or
gray squirrel as a pet in a state that
allows that that if they are moving to
New Hampshire they can bring their pet
with them so representative King thank
you madam chair um two things uh one is
that the amendment says so long as such
animals up to date on any vaccines and
I'm just wondering if that should also
include include some sort of provision
for staying up to- date on vaccines and
then the other question I have is really
just sort of a I don't know a question
to throw out there and that is
I I definitely support the idea that you
know you're moving from out of state you
come in you don't have to give up your
animal but it does put us in this weird
sort of potential legal limbo that you
know people moving from out of state
have more rights than natives um and I'm
just wondering if that's even
constitutional I don't know I honestly
don't know I just thought it would be an
interesting topic thank you
representative kto thank you madam chair
um just a quick question when it says up
to-date on any vaccines required
um are they required to have a rabies
vaccine because I think um different
states could have different vaccine
requirements but I think with New
Hampshire rabies is always required so
Michel I don't know represent Scully and
then Howard thank thank you madam chair
I I had said earlier personally that I
think uh trying to let people legally
own raccoons as a not non-starter for me
because of the fact that they are bigger
more dangerous and they also have a much
higher chance of being infected with
rabies and I believe the testimony
before our committee was that there is
no vaccine schedule for these animals
because they're considered wild animals
and it does seem weird that we would
give special rights to somebody moving
into the state when we're saying you
can't have these animals you know to the
people of New Hampshire who who actually
live here so I I I I think I
love representative Spain's heart's in
the right place but uh I would not vote
for the base Bill and quite honestly I
wouldn't vote for this amendment either
okay thank
you representative Bixby yeah so um oh
I'm sorry Howard I'm sorry I'm so sorry
thank you madam chair um I I uh he stole
one of my points and that is the the
vaccination there is no schedule there
is no requirement there is there isn't
even one that's made for them so that
that's a problem there I also think that
um the proof of whether where you know
the origins of your pet ship of these
animals whether it happened on another
side of the Border or inside our borders
it would be a hard thing to prove thank
you represent Bixby and then represent
so I'd like to chair for to thank the
chair for handing out a copy of current
statute uh and uh where it says um at
the beginning of the section uh import
possession or release of Wildlife no
person shall import possess cell exhibit
or release any Marine wild spe uh live
marine species or Wildlife or the eggs
or progeny thereof without first
obtaining a permit from the executive
director accept its permitted under tile
um 18 the director the executive
director shall have the authority to
determine the time and any other
conditions governing the issuance of the
permit the chief wild of the wildlife
division shall respond to the request
for a permit within 60 days of
submission for final request and there's
a capacity for appeal so there is a
mechanism existing in law for a small
for you know
those small number of individuals who uh
do want to bring uh a uh Wildlife into
the state that they have in their
possession uh so there the the procedure
exists it has the oversight I don't
think we need to make a law that create
could create Lo loopholes to that oh my
God you just convinced me to it all this
bill representative minor thank you
madam chair I'm not certain did you just
say recommend this for itl absolutely
okay
represent okay thank you madam chair I
totally agree I this gives this gives an
effect more rights to a squirrel and
raccoon and we have a dog all right
thank you all right we'll move on from
this I'm I'm done
okay okay allowing for the sale of
freeze-dried foods produced in Homestead
food operations okay so here's a deal
with this the amendment is ready it's
upstairs I just got a a thing from
OS um yeah if you may it's uh 505 HB 505
and it should be a
there um so I met with uh people from
food safety um Friday and also Monday
and we came up with a plan um and the
plan is um I guess I'm going to also
talk about the dehydrated meat bill
which is the next bill on our
list um because of the nature of the
dehydrated meat because of me meat is
being so potentially
hazardous um think that that bill should
be
ited uh we're not ready to do anything
with that right now but um we've come to
the conclusion for um at least
freeze-dried
foods
that
um if if and I have language for this uh
a person can sell freeze-dried
food and that incl includes vegetables
that includes fruit that includes
processed dairy products like yogurt or
ice
cream that what they can do is is go
through the process of getting a
homestead food license which costs like
$150 a year um they would then also um
take a food safety class because these
foods are also potentially hazardous and
we not we understand that we're taking a
potentially hazardous food and making it
into a self stable freeze-dried product
um and that also they should go through
a process review so that there's at
least some oversight to see that what
they're doing is they're doing it
properly and I don't think that that's
really um um a a heavy ask to do for
somebody who's going to be doing this
and producing these Foods uh and is also
gives a level of protection to the
public who's going to be consuming them
so that's where this is and um DHHS was
kind enough to provide some language
where we would establish this in uh RSA
143a colon uh ayen 12 section 4 to read
that Homestead food operations
processing and selling freeze-dried
foods from the homestead residents so
they don't need a commercial kitchen or
anything just from their Homestead
residence in their kitchen
uh at the owner's owned Farm Stand at
farmers markets and they can also sell
their product in retail
stores um not the internet that's not
indicated here um stores shall be
licensed under RSA 143a colon 4 and for
the purposes of this section
freeze-dried food means fruits
vegetables and commercially prepared
dairy products so it gives them a wide
variety of products that they can
produce it gives us um some oversight in
how that process is done um
and uh also allows them to sell this in
retail food stores so representative
barar you had your hand yes thank you
madam chair I'm curious um defining
process review I know that there's a
stumbling block uh to uh the gentleman
who testified um regarding freeze drying
where he had to send recipes and all
kinds of information
um uh and it cost a tremendous amount of
money it was very cumbersome so could
you just Define for me what process
review means in this context um if I may
have uh one of the gals from Food Safety
Division clarify that
please okay see if we can do this
thank you for the opportunity to speak
for the record my name is Michelle
robers I'm the bureau chief for public
health protection within the division of
Public Health
Services and I'm Erica Davis the
administrator of the food protection
section um Department of Health and
Human Services Division of Public Safety
public
health so hap happy to answer your
question so um a process review um helps
us understand uh the the the process
itself is is safe in terms of not um so
that the end product is shelf shelf
stable and typically those Pro those
processes aren't done at the state so
those are handled I think there's the
two closest to us are at Cornell
University and the University of Maine I
believe and um the costs varied between
them but I think it's about actually you
probably know more than I do it does
depend on the product um and the place
that you're having the process valuation
completed um it it can be a stumbling
block um but it really gives us that
understanding of the product and the
process um to ensure that the final
product is at the proper um it has been
produced properly um to be safe to
sell and the cost is about it it it does
depend it can be under main can be under
300 um there are Main and Cornell are
not the only two that you can send out
to there are are other a list of other
process reviewers that will um evaluate
products uh thank you can I any other
question for them uh not a question I
just wanted to summarize
um again this was the stumbling block
for my constituent who came to testify
and they shut his his dreams down it was
the process review which was a huge
issue for
him um his testimony is part of the
record I'll take a look and okay if um
represent Bixby I'm sorry King and then
Bixby I know that we are doing a study
committee to look at the process
review um so I I'm inclined to put that
in right now and then come back to it uh
at a later time to revise that but
anyway representative king um thank you
madam chair um two quick questions one
or one question one statement um was
this bill worked on by the food safety
subcommittee at all has this had you was
there I think we have a food safety
subcommittee yeah we did did this ever
get worked on yeah we did we had uh we
met and we talked about both
bills um we
had I had the two Amendment ments and
I'm trying to find them here oh here I
we had the two amendments and had some
discussion on it
um and um you know came up with some
ideas about it but
um it wasn't something that um the Food
Safety Division would have supported M
and this is something that they would
support okay and um the reason I asked
mainly is because uh we're waiting on
the actual HB 505 Amendment right we
okay um the only thing I would say to
that is that it's we're supposed to have
an exec session on 505 today and I
personally would not feel comfortable
voting on that until I think I need to
like spend some time on this over the
week I'd like to get the because it's
not just going to be a a you know comma
half sentence change that the amendment
it's going to be like a
substantive uh Amendment and I I
personally would like it if we'd recess
505 until next week if that's okay yeah
that's not a problem represent I think
that recessing it till next week makes a
lot of sense uh because well for all the
reasons that uh representative King
explained yep yep okay well that's the
plan
then okay um so I do have thank you
ladies thank you so much so I do have a
copy of the amendment I'm going to send
it around uh and we can
uh we can
sure thank you m chair uh does um
getting a homestead license trigger a
home
inspection uh does getting a homestead
license trigger a home
inspection so if you have a homestead
license do you get an inspection you do
yes thank
you okay
my my no my knowledge was yes but I
didn't want to speak at a turn so that's
for sure okay all right well so um again
I think you know um the way we're going
to deal with 642 the dehydrated meat
bill is um I prefer to itl that even
though it's my bill um and 505 we have
this amendment and we can uh think about
it over the week if people have any
comments they can email me
okay and now so just looking at time 707
do we how much discussion is that going
to take
um
hb77 um I'll let representative Penza
tell us what what's news on SB on
hb77 that's not something that we are
going to exec out today um but I know
that the the um um Solid Waste
subcommittee met the this morning so
would you like to give us an update on
that thank you madam chair I'd like to
uh hand over the uh speaking on this to
representative
Penza uh thank you madam chair um so we
went through
um
quickly the amendment and um there was a
couple things that were not put
incorrectly from OS in regards with um
aquifer language which will basically
change to like drinking water wells um
in a couple of those places
um we
discussed there were questions about
[Music]
um um page three um in regards lines 18
through 24
[Music]
um for uh you know signifant you know
basically denying a permit for
significant history of repeated serious
violations um director whims was kind
enough to speak to this um we could
modify this a bit uh you know look
through what is in current rules right
now see where um I still think there's a
couple gaps I still would would like to
have something like this in here um it
also gives the discretion to the agency
um as well um so there's that piece that
might change a little bit
[Music]
um if everybody wants me to remove the
Ford act lines 15 161 17 from page three
I will be happy to do so it um it really
it it's it's federal law it shouldn't
matter
um it being there or not there so um but
if you guys want it removed if that's a
consensus here I will remove it
um and I did want to say just because I
think a point is is really important and
I just wanted on the record um you know
the point of mentioning of when the bill
was first designed the point of
mentioning the aquifer is really Crystal
Clear we want to protect it so you you
know you basically you protect New
Hampshire's drinking water by not
polluting the same formation where the
water originates that's it so but I will
make sure that OS has got it
specifically in there with drinking
water wells and all of that throughout
the bill but I just wanted that to be on
record um that's really important so
everything else
[Music]
um in here has been changed from the
setback where we talked here's there's
the map on the table so um the 3000t
setback map that we have that we had
previously here is the new one which is
the
1500 which um opens up the universe more
uh it was it basically left about um
3,000 left about
43% I believe of the state available
like if we needed to have another
landfill um this I this probably brings
it up to um maybe closer to 60% or
something like that um the director
whims could speak to that possibly but
um there's a lot more white space here
so that's good to know um and other than
that um all of the issues where um it
was more restrictive with
it being 10 miles from superf fund all
of those things have been
removed um descriptions have been
changed just so that they match exactly
what the bill is speaking to
and um I will bring these minor changes
to um to
OLS uh today and have them fix that and
get this back out um to all of you and
of course if there's anything else here
that you're thinking that we should
discuss in changing um yeah speak now or
forever representative King thank you
madam chair I just want to let the
committee know that the solid waste
subcommittee's views on this bill are
not unanimous um hope I'm not throwing
representative Scully under the bus but
um I think he generally opposes the bill
from what I could understand and I
mention that partly because there's talk
that we may try and get this bill into
the uh
hb2 and you know that we might have like
a committee letter um to do that but I
think it's important to respect uh the
uh the thoughts and opinions of all the
committee members and that we might not
have unanimous consent as far as that is
concerned so if maybe he would like to
speak on that but I just wanted to uh
mention that I presum
Scully well since my name was
mentioned um I will tell you I'm
actually much more comfortable with this
version of the bill than I was with the
original one that had so many
restrictions my my great concern is that
we're going to uh without fully thinking
of the implications create con uh
restrictions that will ultimately shoot
us in the foot down the road when it
comes time to actually put a landfill in
especially if you found one that um met
uh what I hope to be past our new Ben
you know beneficial use uh evaluation
and so the fewer restrictions we put in
here categorically the more comfortable
I am with this for instance that the uh
fiveyear um travel time very comfortable
with that um the arbitrary setback I I
still have to get my my head around um
to say whether we ought to be doing both
if we have a good functional um you know
requirement saying in terms of 5-year
travel time for anything that might
escape a landfill um I did think
the that section 24 which is on uh page
three I felt the language was very vague
and it sounds like we have the
functional equivalence of that already
in rules I think we ought to consider
just dropping that because it sounds
like it's already covered um I did I
actually had one other question for the
uh the the director I don't know if if
it's appropriate for us to asked this
sure if you have a question for the
director and he's here okay please uh
please ask him your question well thank
you thank you director yeah thank thank
you um so representative Penza has a
provision in here to have 247 coverage
at the landfill and she has cited that
there's been actual releases that
occurred because the monitoring system
has failed um is this a reasonable
requirement to put in for any future
landfill um you know installations here
in New Hampshire yeah I I think that
thank you for the question Mike wisat
for the record director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Dees um I I think I did speak to this
earlier and and I believe what I said
was that we believe that um at the
agency that actually the resources that
be be required to do that would be
better spent on um electronic and autom
alarms that would ensure that a
responsible party a person on call what
have you would be um would be notified
um and could come to the facility and
the reason for that is that uh and again
I I think in many respects it' be more
appropriate for the for the um regulated
Community to respond to this as well but
uh it strikes as there's a lot of costs
associated with keeping someone at a
facility
247 it is not clear to us that that
would necessarily result unless that
person were particularly um
knowledgeable about the operation of the
landfill um and more likely it would be
like a security guard that they wouldn't
necessarily know that something was
wrong and so we're not we're just not
convinced that that's maybe the best way
to use the resources to ensure that a
release or or some kind of a a problem
or incident that a landfill was detected
may I ask a followup to you may ask a
followup but I also want to interject
something I've been to U this past week
um the uh folks for the New Hampshire
clean water had a uh an event a
breakfast and they were talking about um
credible and and real threats to these
different
installations not only water places but
certainly other facilities that use
software or um electronic means to to
monitor these kinds of things and how
those uh those facilities can be hacked
into um by anybody who is you know
looking to seek uh to make damage to
these areas so um I can appreciate
having a person on site to actually
monitor things as opposed to letting it
be
monitored remotely or whatever which
could be hacked into um so go ahead
repres of Scully that's kind of my my
thought behind this too okay well um a
good point because I was going to ask uh
if you
were suggesting or recommending that we
rely on the technology for vote
monitoring uh is there some way to
significantly strengthen and tighten
this up so the possibilities of a
problem could be minimized we actually
did address that in our most recent rul
making in which we made specific
requirements associated with automated
diet ERS that would dial continue to
dial responsible facility Personnel
every 10 minutes until until they were
responsive okay representative Bixby and
then I'm gonna back here yes so um I'd
be comfortable not having someone
actually on site 247 as long as there is
someone who is essentially on call 247
that could be could quickly respond to
uh a an
automated
uh alert system like that is that is
appropriately hardened to not be S
generally available on the internet
Etc sure
um you and then
guber and then down that way thank you
madam chair I just have a question and
I'm not sure if this is for you director
or for someone on the committee here but
on page two line 20 um all throughout
the bill we talk about the 5year
distance of travel except on line 20
it's or500 ft now why are we doing that
and what is the importance of that um
you know because if the 5year distance
of travel is really what we're relying
on for everything why do we have that
you want to answer that representative
Penza yeah I'd like to answer that so um
the need for a combination of basically
travel time and some kind of um
distance Bas like minimal setback in a
sense is because if there is a
catastrophic um surface spill then you
really don't want to be so close to like
a lake or a river or something like that
um so that's the reason why you have
both both are in rules right now and it
needs to be and it needs to be longer so
um you just have to make sure that when
it if it flows right into the ground and
above ground that it's not going right
down to where it should be so that's why
you have both thank you for that and
what is the current uh distance right
now
500 thank you uh we had do we have did I
say someone else here guber yeah
representative Gruber and then over to
this end great U uh oh min
I don't want toat death anymore I just
have two two two items one for uh thank
you for being here commissioner the um
do you do you believe on the refer to
this uh Staffing on on site 24 hours 24
hours a day
um I'm I'm leaning towards the same
point that there should be technology
and 24-hour coverage with backup power
what whatever it is uh with today's
technology that can't be easily um uh
violated uh do you think that a uh
off-site person with the technology
could provide equal or better uh
security for a uh an event to be uh
identify in a timely manner well I I
think as I as I've testified um we think
that the the resources going towards a
robust system of electronic um and
notification
you know systems is probably the most
helpful going to the the note that was
made before by I think representative
bxby about having a person designated as
on call my I suspect that facilities are
are essentially doing that that they
that most of our major facilities would
have a person who is uh expected to be
ready to respond if there's an after
hours incident and and certainly you
know to the extent that they don't have
that they should so if that were
something something that want you know
that the committee wanted to put into
the bill I think that would might make
some sense I don't think our rules
specifically address that topic question
sure was um uh for this uh page three uh
lines 18 through 24 we're talking about
um the information provided for what we
have in rules right now um would uh
representative P would she would that be
basically meet your needs uh uh I think
it would meet my needs if if we looked
at it because there seem to be fairly
robust uh rules on um through uh they're
in place for lines 18 to 24 on page
three regarding um who the individual
organization
characters
um let me can you tell me the lines
again page three it's regarding the
issue of uh the history of V you know
make sure that who who runs these
facilities has the proper uh well they
don't have a record that's inappropriate
for who should be running these
important facilities line 18 line 18
yeah 18 through 24 on page three that so
you're saying that section you're saying
I I the whole thing well no I'm not
saying Nick it but look at the what we
have for language all right and
necessary but not we talked about that
in the Sub sub committee um
would you be willing to have that
conversation with me of course okay um I
want to go back
to the page three about having a a
person
contracted we have um all of the
technology in the world that having in
rules right now all of the monitoring
systems which you know um all of that
that's already in place I get that um
but there's nothing that's a fails sayfe
for someone being there eyes and ears
and and hearing it and so I understand
there could be an on call person that
obviously would have to be close by or
something like that but we're talking
about a a private facility that
makes this is a billion dooll you know
one of them that's in Rochester that's a
billion doll or more company to have to
require to have one person there on
staff to um be monitoring and all of the
electronic that's already in place I
just I still don't I don't get that
especially with the level of um just in
the last week the level of infiltration
that has happened to some of the highest
tech companies right now that's going on
from hacking to all of that do
you where do you where do you want to
create Havoc Water waste what you could
do to something is is unbelievable and
and I just technology is all fine and
dandy and we're going to have all of
that I I you know I argue that this is
you know in here if the entire committee
is against it I will pull it that's fine
I'm going to go with consensus but um I
I don't know why we're we're looking to
um save money for for a very profitable
industry um representative wheeler I'm
going to work my way up this way thank
you madam chair just to concur with what
representative Penza
said if organizations businesses like
Sony
or Enron or Exxon excuse me or these big
oil Industries these big very
well-funded almost trillion dollar
Industries billion dollar companies can
get hacked and have their system is
hacked in a way that releases all the
data of everyone in the country or
significant information about critical
resources in our country all this is
happening right now if those things can
happen and if the United States
government the federal government of the
United States of America can get hacked
then I think that these companies can
get hacked too and I don't know if there
is to answer representative scully's
question from a few minutes ago a fail
safe for technology and as
representative Penza said you can't you
can't beat the eyes and the ears being
there on the ground listening seeing and
actually getting to interact with the
facility and given the fact that this is
a company that I think could afford
these fail safes it should be something
that the legislature moves on forward to
say that this is something somebody
should be at the facility watching it so
that we can actually know and see and
hear what's going on at that facility
that makes complete sense to me okay
representative germana thank you madam
chair yeah I'll just say it real quickly
kind of one of the favorite sayings of
our former colleague on this committee
represented of Murray was belts and
suspenders right that you have two
systems of protection and this goes both
for the setback distance there's travel
time and there's also the 1500 ft and
representative patens spoke to that well
if you have a massive surface spill you
want to make sure that you're not so
close to a body of water surface uh
speed being different and faster than
subsurface speed so that's a sec two
layers of protection I think that's a
good thing and likewise with this
question about monitoring in person and
monitoring with technology I think we
need it both our the most important
Safety Systems we have when we're
talking about transportation for example
uh incorporate both human oversight and
electronic monitoring and I think that
is exactly the measure of safety we
should be insisting on here
represent Bixby okay I have two points
uh one is a um practical point one one
one is just I'd like to concur with what
representative gerana just said I am
happy to go with uh with with some with
having that um someone onsite all the
time uh I I think that it's not a
particularly big ask for a company of
the size that would be running up the
landfill uh the other thing is um I
would like to ask representative poent
tza to uh
have have OSS provide a due date for ol
that is soon enough so that you can then
distribute the whole the uh the revised
Amendment to the committee so we have a
couple of days to look it
over thank you representative Scully I'm
sorry I just I'm sorry representative
King first then represent Scully thank
you madam chair and I just want to
piggyback on what Representatives
wheeler Jer and Bixby said I to agree
that it's good to have somebody on site
you know um corporations will often
employ security guards to guard like
light bulbs that are just sitting there
and do nothing so if if these
Corporation if these companies can can
hire security guards to to protect
something that's uh inert uh then we
should also be uh demanding protection
for something that could potentially
ruin the environment and the thing is is
that the cost of this employee is going
to be passed on to the consumers and I
think it's important that that actually
happens that's a good thing because when
municipalities are determining how to
dispose of their waste they need to take
into account all of the costs of their
waste and the thing is is that for too
long um we've been able to uh basically
just um cut the cost of the waste at the
expense of the environment and I don't
like that I think that you know when you
it's like when you buy a product you're
buying a a something that's wrapped in
plastic and it's like okay you've paid
for the cost of of the product but you
haven't yet paid for the cost of the
disposal of the product and I think it's
important that all the true cost the
true the the true charges that would add
up to disposal are in there and if this
is another charge that's going to be
added on to
municipalities my goal My Hope Is that
eventually municipalities are going to
say you know what the charges the cost
of disposing things in the ground is
more than some other method like for
example waste energy incineration plants
or maybe even shipping it to a location
that's not as environmentally hazardous
as it is here so so for me I'm in no way
shape or form uh liking the idea of
trying to cut costs for um for landfills
I think we need to jack those costs up
to Infinity thank
you represent representa
Scully um I I guess I would just point
out that um I understand people's
concerns about remote hacking but if
you've got like a simple Sump System
that has a monitor that tells you when a
level's been reached in a tank you can
set that system up such that your safety
equipment is not uh you C you cannot
change what it does remotely what we're
really talking about is whether an an
alarm is struck a level is reached and
that message is then sent remotely to
somebody else so I mean I guess you
could think of North Korean hackers
coming in and saying we're we're going
to keep somebody from getting that you
know alarm that the level has been
reached but the systems themselves can
be set up such that they're they're a
Clos system there's a firewall there and
you can't go in and hack those things to
stop their safety functions from
occurring represent Penza did you guys
have
anything all right represent Penza uh
thank you madam chair my last point on
this because I think we've really um
uh gone around and around is is this so
the security piece that was just
mentioned um that right there alone is
the reason why someone should be there
all of the time a person should be there
all of the time on site it is very easy
especially with a landfill um like we
have in Rochester which is the largest
in the state for someone to come in and
set it on fire so just so you know
that's very easy to do so we've got
gases that are coming out and all of
that kind of stuff so if you just look
at that piece and that piece alone for
security um that's huge I mean
everything's posted all over that
property the you can very easily um
there's lots of hazardous you know um
materials and stuff like that that are
there I'm not talking about hazardous
waste I'm talking about materials and
places like that that just for security
reasons Alone um we should have there
should be somebody there not even
talking about when you know about
releases or something catastrophic that
could happen to the
environment okay thank you I think uh
We've pretty much ended discussion on uh
hb77 I've just passed out
um a proposed house resolution um this
is uh with in response to the um meet
Slaughter Bill and and thank you uh
director wiim whims for um taking our
questions um so the meat Slaughter bill
which we
retained
um represent Bixby and I I just have a
question could we perhaps um uh recess
the work session and go to caucus for
five minutes to figure out what we're
doing and then take up the res
resolution uh after the um exec session
because we're running like about well I
wanted I wanted to just explain this
before we go to caucus okay fair enough
um and I think we're pretty much done
with our work session so I don't know
that we need to recess that okay um the
uh this proposed house resolution I
wanted to explain it to you before we go
into a caucus before we exec some bills
out
um because of we retained that meat
Slaughter Bill and um we wanted to have
a house resolution much like the house
resolution that was presented by Ways
and Means last Thursday on the house
floor um what I was told by clerk Paul
Smith was that if we as a committee vote
on this proposed house
resolution and we agree on it that then
we can take this language to OS have it
drafted and bring it to the house floor
just like Ways and Means did with their
uh Revenue estimates
so I'm worked on uh representative Bixby
took language that we had from um uh
Farm
Bureau and um because Farm Bureau gave
us the house resolution representative
Bix be paired it down um and then um I
met with um Farm Bureau yesterday uh and
they had a couple other changes so this
is the end document um basically urging
our federal delegation to sponsor
legislation and also urging the United
States Department of Agriculture to
adopt regulations allowing for
smallscale Slaughter plants to use the
federal Meat Inspection acts custom
exempt meat processing inspection
criteria with a third-party inspector
present at Slaughter so that processed
beef pork lamb and Chevron goat meat can
be sold as individual Cuts directly from
the farm producer to the end consumer
This was um
HB thank you yes
uhu so that's what this house resolution
is and I hope that um when we finish
executing our bills we will uh I would
like to vote on this house resolution as
a committee and I hope that you will
support it so with that I'm going to um
adjourn in our work session like and
uh let's meet for caucus for about 10 or
15 minutes 10
minutes yeah quarter of will be back
here and then we can take up uh exacting
the bills that we have on our list to
exact
today
e
e e
overnight got uh very sick uh and had a
fever and didn't sleep it yeah it just
hit her overnight I hope she feels
better soon
okay I am going to open up our exec
sessions this
afternoon um sorry we're late we're
running late on this um we will start
with HB 424 directing the Department of
Agriculture markets and food to create
forms for businesses to request
information about service animals and
establishing a committee to study the
protection of business owners from
requests to accommodate customers with
fraudulent or untrained service
animals do I hear a motion
representative Howard I move itl on HB
424 and do I hear a
second I'll second that thank you
representative Freeman representative
Howard would you like to speak to your
motion um I we've discussed it at almost
great enough length I just think that we
it's an unnecessary bill because our
hands are tied by the federal Ada
laws thank you any other discussion
about this bill
seeing none I request the uh clerk to
call the role on itl motion for HB
424 Vice chairwoman
coma
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza yes representative
Freeman yes clerk votes yes
representative Scully yes representative
bar ber yes representative Miner yes
ranking member Bixby yes representative
germana yes representative Howard yes
representative wheeler y representative
guber yes chairwoman Aaron yes motion
passes 14 to
nothing thank you going to close the
exec on HB 424 consent calendar oh does
yes
should we put this on the cons calendar
yes thank you U close the exec on HB
424 uh I will open up the exec session
for hb401 relative to animal testing
funded by New Hampshire state fund 262
oh I'm sorry I'm on the Oh wrong wrong
thing here
262 uh well we have HB I'm sorry we have
hb250 I'm going to open up the exec
session for
hp250 and I'm going to suggest that we
recess this um till next week uh pending
um uh updated amendment to that bill um
and we will recess that to um I
guess what would be Yeah March
18th uh
10:30 uh right after we get back from or
yeah I guess 10:30 yeah well you know
what we should have a work session first
so on on the four bills and then have a
caucus so let's call it
11:15 okay did you get in touch with uh
uh CSG about them po presenting and they
would be coming to um speak with us
around 11:30 okay so we'll have like 15
minutes to exec four bills okay so let's
say
11:15 on um March
18th okay moving right along HB
262 which is relative to group license
for dogs do I hear a motion yes I'd like
to move itl on that do I hear a second
second that yeah thank you
representative Bixby would you like to
speak to your motion okay I pretty much
said what needed to be said in the work
session uh so um I think we can just
vote okay I request the um clerk to call
the role on HB the motion of itl for HB
262 Vice chairwoman ktoa yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby yes representative germana yes
representative H
Haskins oh my apologies representative
Howard yes representative wheeler yay
representative guber
yes rank uh chair Roman Aaron
yes 14 nothing motion passes uh should
that be on consent yes please all right
we're good with that all right I close
the exec session for HB
262 and move along to open the exec for
hb401 relative to animal testing funded
by New Hampshire State funds do I hear a
motion for that yes Madam chair I move
to itl or inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 401 thank you representative
Freeman do I hear a second second Madam
chair representative germana second and
representative Freeman would you like to
speak to your motion short and sweet
essentially this bill is a solution
searching for a problem New Hampshire
currently only has one inst State
Cosmetics company who voluntarily
doesn't test on animals and finally our
instate universities must comply with
federal guidelines pertaining to any
animal testing or research so for those
reasons I feel that this bill is
unnecessary is there any further
comment seeing none I'd like to have the
clerk call the role on itl motion for
hb401 vice chairwoman ktoa yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby yes representative germana yes
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber
yes chairman Aon yes 14 nothing motion
passes shall that be placed on consent
yes please okay thank you very much I'm
going to close the exec session for
hb401 I'm going to open up the exec
session for HB
505 and I would like to
um uh no I'd like to uh recess this bill
again uh this is the allowing for the
sale of freeze-dried foods produced in
Homestead food operations
um we have a um an amendment pending
which is not ready for today um and so
I'd like to recess this um exec session
for um March 18th at 11:15
a.m. and I'm going to close the
uh that HB
505 and move on to HB
642 allowing the sale of DEH hydrated
meat without a homestead food license
and I would like to move itl on that do
I hear a second representative Howard
seconds and I'll speak to my
motion um in speaking with both the food
safety subcommittee and what we wanted
to do and in conjunction with uh my
conversations with Food Safety Division
and the
HHS I believe that more thought needs to
be put into introducing this type of
meat product into Homestead food sales
um meat is a very different
product than some of the other things
that we've discussed uh is a potentially
hazardous food handling of meat is uh
nothing to be taken lightly and I think
um since this is even my bill I'd like
to think more thoroughly on how this
type of potentially hazardous food can
be prod produced and sold with just a
little bit more oversight and um in this
manner anyway so that is my reasoning
for wanting to itl this bill is there
any other further comment
or discussion on
this seeing none um I would like to the
clerk to call the role on the itl motion
for HB
642 Vice chairwoman ktoa yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
yes um representative germana yes
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative grber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes 14 nothing motion
passes okay thank
you you want to put that on consent yes
please thank
you all right um I'm going to close the
exec session for HB 642 and open up the
exec session for HB 251 allowing the
ownership of certain squirrels and
raccoons do I hear a motion
Madam chair I move that this bill be uh
voted on as in expedient to legislate
okay do I hear a
second second representative Bixby
second representative Scully would you
like to speak to your motion well I
think this bill is very well-meaning but
based on the expert testimony of our
fish and wildlife individuals these are
wild animals there is no established
vaccine schedule which heightens the
danger of trying to keep them as pets
and therefore we believe that this would
be an unsafe U thing to allow people to
do so I say that this should be
inexpedient to legislate any further
question um representative King thank
you madam chair um I'm going to be
voting no against the motion um there's
two main reasons why people have a
problem with this bill and that is that
uh it would be dangerous to humans or it
would be unethical for Animals I think
both of those arguments fall flat
because um while squirrels and raccoons
may bite so do dogs and people get
killed from dogs all the time uh we
don't ban them furthermore um uh while
those may be Wildlife um actually all
animals are wildlife and we also have a
lot of animals that um um probably would
prefer to stay wild such as birds that
we cage so all of the animals that um I
think there are a lot of animals that we
do allow that um so if we do allow those
animals I think we should also allow
raccoons and squirrels and then the last
argument is well there's no vaccine
schedule well there's no vaccine
schedule because they're banned they're
just not allowed if we allowed them then
there would be a vaccine schedule so I
think if you go through each one of the
arguments against you could
systematically defeat them with basic
logic so that's why I'm going to be
voting uh against the motion but um I'm
fine with the going on consent calendar
once it gets defeated thank you
representative Bixby yeah in addition to
all the
uh reasons that representative Freeman
cited sorry representative Scully cited
uh also there is existing in uh ficient
game laws a method a mechanism for
permitting in the small number of cases
where it might be
relevant representative wheeler thank
you madam chair I think representative
King outlaid the I think representative
King handled it well I just believe that
this is sort of uh it's a silly Bill
both ways whoever you look at it and I
think I'll be voting in favor of
allowing people to own squirrels because
it's
uh not
as not significantly enough dangerous
for me to say that the state should ban
the use of them would I say go out there
and own a squirrel No but it's also not
for me to say and I think somebody has
the right if they come into the state
having own own a squirrel to own that
squirrel and from a more funnier
perspective I think of that squirrel
that died last year peanut and you know
the state of New Hampshire doesn't want
to get itself in any peanut scandals
but thank you any other comment or
question seeing none I asked the clerk
to call the rule on itl motion for uh
hb21 Vice chairwoman comto yes
representative Kenny
yes representative Penza yes
representative Freeman yes clerk votes
no representative Scully yes
representative Barber yes representative
Miner yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative germana
yes uh representative Howard yes
representative
wheeler yeah no representative guber yes
chairman
Aon uh on itl
yes uh motion passes 12-
two can we put this on the consent
calendar you're fine with that okay um
I'm fine with it
too uh is there a Minority Report
anybody interested in writing one there
can't be a Minority Report if it's yeah
never mind okay all right I'm going to
close the hearing for
hb21 and open up the hearing the um I'm
sorry the exact open up the exact for
hb152 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent
traps I am going to move itl on this
bill and do I hear a
second I'll second that oh oh represent
representative Freeman I'll second that
you wanted to second that okay
sorry okay and I will speak to my
motion um rodent and rodent infestation
is a problem rodents carry diseases like
black plague and in the interest of
Public Health I will side with the
health of human beings and support the
use of all uh non-chemical means to
eliminate problem problematic rodents uh
any way that you kill a rodent is going
to be considered cruel and um I I saw
that testimony uh for the use of glue
traps that that that is an effective way
to Monitor and capture
rodents um you also cannot control where
people purchase glue traps it would be
simple for people to buy them over the
Internet or go to a neighboring state um
there are instructions on the packages
on how to properly use these products
and I think we need need certainly a lot
more public education on that um so that
non-target species are not being
captured but in the end I I I am very
strongly against Banning any kind of
non-chemical means to control the rodent
population um do I hear other
representative
wheeler thank you madam chair uh I'm
going to vote against the it motion on
this legislation but I do just want to
say and in case this gets brought back
that it should not be under the and the
Department of Agriculture the
commissioner asked us to not have this
the enforcement be under his Department
as it doesn't land there and I think
there are just some serious structural
problems with the legislation that could
be fixed uh if a little bit more work
was put into it so that's for the camera
representative H Haskins if she's at
home if you want to put that work into
the legislation then I think that would
make it a little bit more amenable to
people but uh I am going to vote with
the caucus on this
one represent
Freeman thank you madam chair as someone
um as I seconded this bill I just wanted
to point something out that's come to
light recently Jean Hackman's wife um
was found in her house and her cause of
death was hirus and hirus is a real but
but lethal disease that rats carry only
rats so I'd like to point out that um
while those instances a antivirus may be
rare it's still lethal and if someone is
dealing with the rodent problem and we
limit what they can do in order to
exterminate those rodents then we are
exposing the public to some health risks
and I believe they did have a rodent
problem on their property so yeah
representative jera uh thank you madam
chair I I would have liked to you know
if we had actually worked on amendment I
realized that we understood where the
lines were drawn so it wouldn't have
gotten us gotten us any closer I still
would have would have liked that
Amendment we do in fact have ways of
regulating sales in state and and there
are ways to to Mark certain products is
not for sale in certain States even uh
when it comes to purchasing them online
uh we heard from from some folks that
some desire for us to find some kind of
compromise uh because clearly there is
enough interest in this uh among our
constituents that the bill is going to
come back and we had a representative of
the uh The Pest Control
industry well but he he urged us to work
towards some type of compromise in any
event uh I think there are many
non-chemical options that are both less
cruel and have much less potential uh to
have harmful impacts on other animals so
I'll be voting against the itl
yeah I would also remind people too that
um you know these glue traps are used to
control pests like cockroaches and other
insects and um while this bans them for
the use of rodents glue glue boards um I
don't know how you can enforce using it
for one pest population versus
another um so with that if there's any
no other further conversation I would
ask the clerk to call the role on the
itl motion
of
hb152 Vice chairwoman ktoa
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza yes representative
Freeman yes clerk votes yes
representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
no Representative germana no
representative Howard
no representative wheeler reluctant
no representative
Gruber
no chairwoman Aaron yes on
itl 95 motion
passes okay
um I will be writing the majority report
who would like like to write the minor
report
ger okay I'm going to close the exec
session on
hb152 again we had two of our bills that
we had on our docket today which will be
that have been recessed for next week uh
we will have then four bills to vote on
next week and that will be the end of
what is on our plate um and uh please
get your uh Comm reports into me as soon
as
possible and I want to thank
everybody oh yeah we've got uh this I'm
sorry before we take off we've got this
house resolution to vote on I hope
everybody had a moment to read
it and um I
would entertain any discussion about it
representative Bixby yeah I just like to
point out that um I think this makes a
lot of sense uh
and uh I the it's a little bit longer
than than what I than than the my
revision of it but I think that uh the
changes are fine in terms of I I wasn't
aware that there might be political
problems by mentioning the prime act the
uh Farm Bureau was aware of that so they
asked to not have that language in here
uh their their language is a little bit
more specific in in terms of how it
might work I'm fine with that uh and
representative Aaron added in in that uh
we would be making the ask of both the
federal delegation and also the USDA uh
the USDA can't do anything uh in terms
of regulations unless there's a change
in statute so we need to have um both of
those parties be involved in it um and
uh and I I think that the list of
whereas is is uh sufficiently short but
also sufficiently comprehensive to cover
the reasons that this bill that this
resolution makes sense okay um so I
guess we have to have a motion for a to
pass on this is that how I don't know
yeah I um I can move out to pass okay I
second wouldn't it be a motion for
adoption or adoption maybe it is
adoption yeah sure oh okay motion for
adoption motion to adopt motion to adopt
house resolution I second
it um if there's any other discussion on
this at all
no seeing none um could we do we have
the clerk call the rooll or just yeah
how do you want to do
that we could do a Voice vote if that's
yeah vote because if Paul says that we
should have done a voice I would rather
do a roll call because we should have
done a roll call then I don't want to
have to come back okay correct all right
so I I don't know I guess you can
use one of your forms to do that yeah
just do a roll call vote and we'll
figure it out I suppose I can fill in
whatever I want so um this this house
resolution doesn't have any number does
it right okay so I'll just put that
blank and then I can always fill it in
later something else
um okay Vice chairwoman comtois yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby representative germana yes
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
chairwoman Aaron yes motion passes 14 to
nothing okay super
all right uh I guess that's it for today
and I want to remind everybody uh we
will
be we have been invited on Tuesday
Morning next week on the 18th to the um
the uh yeah breakfast let me just pull
pull this up on my phone here um this is
the young Farmers
breakfast from Farm Bureau uh from 8: to
10 a.m.
at Sunny Crest Farm 59 high Range Road
londondary yep 59 high R I will send out
a reminder to
everybody it is
indoors and um so we'll see you all then
and then um uh the plan is to have a a
work session on the four bills that are
remaining have a quick caucus and then
vote those vote on those four bills in
the meantime I will be working uh with
with uh chairman Wier uh on the language
that's in the trailer Bill to pull that
language out and submit um our
suggestion for the three
um the three bills that will take its
place and that's it just for clarity
you're you're that's going to be in
consultation with the governor's office
which is still in process yes I one one
quick question on the the three bills
that would be HP 171
HB 215 and hb77 and what about Lee plan
HB no that's not going to be included
okay thanks doesn't need to be okay
great thank you okay we are convened
thank you so much do I hear a motion to
adjourn so moved second all those in
favor
I
by thank you thank you you had an extra
resolution here I took fur yeah oh where
dider I wanted to see you get up there
and give a um a moment of silence for
school I almost did I didn't want to be
too disrespectful to the bill
okay for